how's it going everybody it's Warren and
we have some major major major news
today the video that I've been waiting
to do for a very long time now
spider-man is officially saved
that's right spider-man is 100% staying
in the MCU according to an article from
Variety Sony and Disney worked out a
deal and spider-man is going to stay in
the MCU the article from Variety goes on
to say that Marvel Studios and its
President Kevin Feige are going to be
the ones who produce the third
spider-man film and it will be in the
MCU this will be the third spider-man
film in the Home Coming series and of
course at will start Tom Holland the
next spider-man film is scheduled for
release on July 16th 2021 and according
to the article not only are we going to
get another spider-man film in the MCU
but spider-man will appear in other MCU
movies in the future as well Amy Pascal
is going to produce the third spider-man
film through Pascal pictures what she
did for the first two spider-man films
Kevin Feige in the article goes on to
say I am thrilled that Spidey's journey
and the MCU will continue and I and all
of us at Marvel Studios are very excited
that we got to keep working on it
spider-man is a powerful icon and a hero
whose story crosses all ages and
audiences around the globe he also
happens to be the only hero with the
super power to cross cinematic universes
so as Sony continues to develop their
own Spidey verse you never know what
surprises the future might hold now if
you're like me when you hear that you
think of one thing and one thing only
venom so it seems like both parties of
the sony disney deal get what they want
I know there were a lot of people that
wanted spider-man over at Marvel but I
know there were a lot of people that
want in spider-man to stay at Sony
because they want a spider-man Sony film
but they don't want venom to be nerfed
they still want a venom that's pretty
brutal and they thought Disney would
kind of play him down a little bit so
either Tom Holland will be spider-man
and venom verse that Sony has or venom
is going to be coming to the MCU as well
but regardless it is official spider-man
has been saved he is going to remain in
the MCU be sure to let me know how
excited you are that we finally see this
deal come to an end and that we finally
have spy
man once again in the MCU be sure to let
me know in the comments down below of
course don't forget to subscribe to my
channel like this video and comment with
your favorite superhero or villain so
you can enter my giveaway for a chance
to win an Xbox one or a ps4 also follow
me on Twitter and click the link in the
description down below for your chance
to win a Nintendo switch as always thank
you all so much for watching
woof woof